This week, the US
reached a
somber milestone with more mass
shootings than days in the year
That number
making clear the chilling
reality of the gun crisis
that is hitting communities
nationwide, including in Nashvil
where in just days
families will mark one month
since six
teachers and children
were gunned down in an elementar
And ahead of that anniversary,
the Tennessee
governor, Billy,
is now calling
for a special legislative sessio
to tackle gun reform.
Among those pushing
for immediate action
on tighter
gun laws are three state Democra
lawmakers who are dubbed
the Tennessee Three.
They have emerged
as some of the most powerful voi
on gun reform
after being punished for protest
on the Tennessee House floor.
All three of them
are heading to the White House t
to discuss gun violence
and what could be done about it
with President Biden.
And all three of them are here.
Joining me now, Representative
Justin Jones,
Justin Jay Pearson and Gloria Jo
Thank you all for being here.
Representative Jones,
I want to start with you.
I mean, what are you going to te
president tomorrow?
Yeah,
I'm going to lift up
the names
of Akeelah DaSilva, of of Michae
of these children
whose lives were taken in Nashvi
and ask for the president
to declare a public health emerg
when it comes to gun violence.
I think that we need
emergency response
because we're facing crisis situ
and that in states like ours,
we need help from our national l
because we're in a state
where the only action
that our colleagues took in resp
to the mass
shooting in Nashville was to exp
the two youngest black lawmakers
and then to pass a law
to protect gun manufacturers.
That's how they passed this sess
And so we need support
and we must continue the fight
on a nationwide scale.
I just want to play a little bit
President Biden has said about
what he thinks he's able to
do and what he's not. Listen,
I have
drawn the full extent
of my executive authority
to do on my own and think about
Congress has act The majority
of the American people
don't have an assault weapon.
Right.
Do you agree with that?
Do you think that he's maxed out
potential here?
And, you know, I mean, maybe he'
The Congress does need to act,
but is that something that you t
is possible? Right.
So obviously, Congress needs to
and our state legislatures need
We're in a state
where the Republican Party
that's in
control has refused to do
anything substantive
about protecting kids and childr
But for President Biden
and we're fortunate
to have the chance
to be with them tomorrow,
it is also to think about
beyond executive orders,
what other authority exists
within departments and agencies
that the president
is ultimately responsible
for that can call
for a public health emergency.
They can call for resources
to go into communities
that are feeling the harm
of the epidemic of gun violence
the most in order to get mental
resources, in order to get gun p
resources to those places as wel
I think there's
a really a holistic approach
that has to be taken
that isn't just addressing guns,
but it's addressing
how we prevent gun violence
and how we support communities
that are suffering
because of the inaction of peopl
like the Republican Party in Ten
There is also the culture
of guns in this country.
I mean, I think I feel like this
we really saw that so vividly.
We had these three incidents
with young people doing normal,
things being gunned down.
Luckily, some of them survive.
But Representative Johnson,
I mean, you represent actually
a pretty conservative part of Te
I mean,
your district went for Trump
or your district,
which is in a county
that went for Trump
by 15 points
in the last election
in 2016 by 23 points.
How do you see the challenge
of taking on that culture?
Well, you know,
the reality is in my district be
because I'm
a teacher
taught for 27 years
I was in a school
that had a school shooting.
Gun violence has always
been a big issue for me
and I have red run
red flag laws in the past.
But we polled in my district
in red Knox
County and overwhelmingly the ma
of Republicans
in my district support
red flag laws
and independents and Democrats.
So this shouldn't
be difficult in our legislature
many Republicans
also support reform center.
So but it is. So why?
I mean, why?
Well, we as we saw on this week,
the Tennessee
Firearms Association
were standing right in there.
You know, the NRA is big in Tenn
They're big donors
to Republican campaigns
and the Firearms Association.
I mean, they had a letter
that they were passing out
to all Republican members.
It was quite threatening, actual
And they were even sort of haras
some of the women,
some of the moms
that were there
asking for us to talk about gun
They're prominent, they're prese
And they're they're near threats
So Tennessee House
Republicans put out this tweet
on this issue of red flag laws
that says any red flag law
is a nonstarter.
For House Republicans.
Our caucus is focused
on finding solutions
that prevent dangerous individua
from harming the public
and preserve
the Second Amendment
rights of law abiding citizens.
You know, Governor Lee,
who is a Republican,
he says he wants this special se
But what reasonably can
we expect to come out of this
I think movements can change
political priorities.
The reason that this
NRA endorsed governor is calling
a special session is not
because he saw the light,
but because he felt the fire
and pressure of a movement
of thousands
of students,
mothers, community members
come to the Capitol
week after week after week
since this mass shooting occurre
And so what
I also know
some inside knowledge about that
is that I've had Republicans
colleagues tell me that leadersh
put out that statement
without talking
to all the Republican members.
So they put out a statement
on behalf of the caucus
without talking to all of their
many of the moderates
who say we should pass red flag
something that the majority of T
and support
across party line,
because it's not an issue
of left or right,
but it is a moral issue
of right or wrong.
Do you think there are
there is moderate support
in the Tennessee legislature rig
to do something on guns?
And will they be allowed to do i
The reality is
thousands of people
have come to our capital.
Hundreds of thousands of people
have, said
Boehner had phone calls
and emails
going to this Republican majorit
saying that they need to do some
We have folks
who are Republicans holding
signs saying, I'm a Republican.
I want to see common sense gun
control legislation.
The reality is the pressure from
what's happening
outside is forcing
people who are within the instit
to do differently than they othe
are normally would.
And that is what gives me courag
and hope in this moment.
You were going to.
Yeah,
I definitely have hope
because of all the people
that have been coming out.
We did a human chain of eight
almost 9000 people
from Vanderbilt
Hospital to the legislature.
And it is having a difference.
And those Republicans
that he was talking about,
Republicans for gun sense,
they were there every day last w
and just letting people know.
However, you know,
I know that there are some Repub
that would like to vote with thi
whether or not
they will
because they are bullied
in their own caucus.
And it's you know,
will they have the courage?
It's going to take political cou
hopefully they will find that co
to do the right thing
because an overwhelming
majority of Tennesseans
want to see something done.
They want to focus on more secur
and all that in the schools.
And for me,
I want to prevent
guns from ever
getting to the schoolhouse door.
We can do prevention
that keeps guns from getting the
It seems like
they want a gun battle at the do
with a lot of police.
And, you know, let's do it.
Let's think about prevention
and how do we prevent those guns
from getting to the schoolhouse
I want to show this image from e
this week.
Representative Jones,
you were walking into the Tennes
Capitol with a coffin
representing, as you were just s
that the children,
the young children
who were killed this week
These are tactics.
I think some people you know,
you're making a statement there
and some people have criticized
your tactics.
What do you say to them?
So so that casket was actually b
by the clergy who came, clergy
who have buried
children and congregants
who were killed because of gun v
That march was led on behalf
of Reverend William Barber,
the second of the repairs of the
And they asked us to bring that
because they could not bring it
And so we brought in as a symbol
that we must challenge
the policies of death
that my colleagues
on the other
side of the aisle are promoting
that make it easier
to get a gun than it is to get h
care in our state.
And so it was
it was about lifting up the issu
and dramatizing
for the nation
that this is an issue of life or
and that if we leave session
and do nothing,
that we have morally failed
because children, 39 year
olds lost their lives.
In Nashville, where I live,
three adults lost their lives.
Yesterday was the anniversary
of another mass
shooting in Nashville
at the Waffle House,
where four precious
young people lost their lives.
And we've had more mass shooting
this year
than we can even count
because we're not doing anything
And so it is an issue of life or
It is personal
and it requires us to do things
that are out of the ordinary,
like protest on the House floor,
like bring a casket and say, col
look at what we're doing.
There are children dying
and we have to do something to
to do to move the needle forward
And to force action.
There was this week
a member of that body, Scotty Ca
another representative who resig
but only after it was publicly r
that he had been found to
have been guilty of sexual haras
And that happened
prior to YouTube
being expelled from that body.
What's your response
to how that was handled?
Well, Speaker
Cameron Sexton is running a mob
not a democracy.
And in this type of institution,
what he desires and wants is wha
And what he wanted
was to expel lawmakers
for protesting to end gun violen
He wanted to protect a lawmaker
who committed sexual assault
against a 19 year old intern.
That's what
we're dealing with in our state.
We have a supermajority
of the Republican Party
that's way more concerned
about protecting their own,
upholding the systems
of white supremacy and patriarch
than doing something about justi
And so it wasn't until it was pu
Speaker Sexton,
Leader Lambert
actually did something about thi
But it shows the disparity
in treatment
for black lawmakers, for women l
and for the white lawmakers
who are in charge
and operating in the state of Te
And it shows everyone in this na
why we have to continue to be pe
where we have to continue to adv
for change that needs
to happen in Tennessee.